[Musique]
dans l'actualité de ce 6 avril elle
revient pour une deuxième édition à
versailles la bap biennale
d'architecturé de paysage se déroulera
du 13 mai au 13 juillet ce matin la
région ile-de-france présenter
l'événement à son siège de saint-ouen le
rendez-vous aura pour thème cette année
terre et ville et j - 4 avant le premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle hier
attrape le candidat de la france
insoumise jean luc mélenchon a fait une
apparition en hologramme un meeting
virtuel à la merise diffusé en simultané
dans 12 villes de france et puis à
montigny le bretonneux des étudiants de
l'estaca travaille actuellement sur une
voiture de rallye une première pour
l'école d'ingénieurs spécialisée dans
l'e mobilité les deux passionnés de
mécanique espère participer à des
courses rapidement
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ses titres et
cette action en justice de la famille de
samuel pâtit elle porte plainte contre
les ministères de l'intérieur et de
l'éducation nationale pour non
assistance à personne en péril et non
empêchement de crime les proches du
professeur d'histoire-géographie dénonce
une série de défaillances et de lourdes
négligences qui ont conduit à
l'assassinât le 16 octobre 2020 samuel
pâtit avait été décapité par un
terroriste près du collège où il
enseignait à conflans sainte honorine
tué pour avoir montré en classe des
caricatures du prophète mahomet
[Musique]
organisé l'aménagement urbain tout en
préservant la terre voilà la réflexion
au coeur de la seconde biennale
d'architecturé de paysage d'île de
france cet événement se déroulera du 13
mai au 13 juillet 2022 architectes
paysagistes et urbanistes sont mises à
l'honneur à travers la thématique terre
et ville c'est un moment des changes
c'est un moment doré schisme en
culturelle c'est un moment de
présentation c'est un moment au travers
duquel on repense la ville en repenser
urbanisme on repense l'acte de
construire de créer la vie d'essayer de
prendre en compte d' intégrer
l'impératif de l'urgence écologique de
la transition écologique à laquelle nous
sommes confrontés
comment construire une ville plus
durable après l'édition 2019 la cité
royale accueille à nouveau ce rendez
vous versailles est une illustration de
l'esprit de la biennale d'architecturé
de paysage
versailles fait partie des très rares
villes mondes que compte notre pays que
c'est une image connue au delà de nos
frontières c'est un patrimoine
architectural qui est un véritable écrin
pour présenter l'ensemble de ces
expositions au programme de cette
seconde édition de la bap des colloques
et des débats et neuf expositions
proposées au public à travers la ville
de versailles découverte de lauréades
architecture de nouveaux matériaux ou
encore parcours dans le potager du roi
un focus sera aussi fait sur des grands
projets d'urbanisme en ile de france
vous allez avoir deux expositions très
grand public aux médias qui sont l'une
sur la présentation du village olympique
et l'âge olympique a été pensé par
dominique perrault qu'elle commissaire
de cette exposition à un architecte
français très connu en france l
international et puis une autre
exposition qui lie la présentation du
pavillon
sur les projets des cars du grand paris
lors de la première édition en 2019 plus
de deux cent mille visiteurs ont
participé à la biennale d'architecturé
de paysage
[Musique]
jean luc mélenchon était en hologramme
attrape ce mardi 5 avril le meeting
s'est déroulé à la merise pour cette
dernière ligne droite avant le premier
tour des élections présidentielles un
multi meeting depuis lille en simultané
dans onze autres villes clés parmi
lesquels trappe la seule d'ile-de-france
la commune yvelinoise a été choisi selon
plusieurs critères une ville populaire
un maire engagé ou encore le temps de
trajet à notre maire qui soutient jean
luc mélenchon qui fait partie en fait du
parlement d'union populaire et du coup
ça a été aussi à mon avis un critère de
choix pour venir ici dans ce dans cette
ville hautement symbolique dans les
yvelines et en france le critère c'était
aussi que chaque personne qui souhaitait
se rendre à son ultime de logram n'est
pas à se déplacer plus de deux heures
autour de chez elle donc l'idée c'était
aussi de quadriller comme territoire
compte technique déjà utilisée en 2017
lors de la dernière campagne
présidentielle pour ce multi meeting le
nombre de villes en simultané à
augmenter et la technologie a été
améliorée
pourtant il ya quelques années qui sont
passés par exemple hologramme cad en
2017 et un peu moins coloré un peu moins
un peu moins réaliste et c'est
intéressant aussi pour montrer que la
politique bah ça se renouvelle au signal
porte à porte les collages le marché que
je très traditionnelle et qu'on est
qu'on fait depuis toujours et puis aussi
des choses nouvelles qui attire un
public plus jeune un public aussi
curieux de voir les hologrammes près
d'un millier de personnes étaient au
rendez-vous des militants qu'ils
viennent de toute l'ile-de-france
poursuivre le programme et découvrir
l'hologramme je pense est une manière
différente de faire de la politique
c'est bien que ça rentre un peu dans le
21e siècle et qu'on en fasse ça
différemment c'est vraiment un choix
convaincu et surtout
une satisfaction pouvoir voir son
hologramme ce soir il sera avec nous
d'une certaine manière le plus important
c'est le fond c'est le programme c'est
ce programme est vraiment une réponse à
la crise aux crises multiples qu'on
traverse le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle aura lieu ce dimanche 10
avril
[Musique]
ségolène hors auto moore je suis catho
vienne une personne handicapée de
naissance en fait j'ai manqué d'oxygène
à man et thor et taux refi de 2 m à
bouder à tout prix me faire vivre d'où
j'ai eu de réanimation donc camille de
l'animation pour un cerveau c'est énorme
et après je le frac midi vers nation et
ensuite mais bien commence à démarrer et
petit à petit on a découvert les
séquelles du moque de qui
j'adore une future présidente d'un
future présidente
qui est un peu des coudes à une personne
handicapée et fait rare qu'un bon but
des tarifs en public vraiment à créer un
fonds d'un choc nous avions besoin de
demander de être pour toi au
propriétaire ou à
je pense que vaut pas moins d'être déjà
et tout ce qu'ils voient les bâtiments
publics qui date un peu de rentrer
aux puits après oui à penneteau pour
désintoxiquer allocation aux adultes
handicapés du tout moi je vois comme
game avait un profil youtube et radio
n'ai droit à rien puisque jérôme les
coupes qui coûte donc moi j'ai zéro par
mois
[Musique]
en 2021 l'air a été légèrement plus
respirable en ile-de-france conclusions
du dernier bilan des repas rifle
organisme chargé de la surveillance de
la qualité de l'air dans la région
baisse des émissions de dioxyde d'azoté
des particules fines seul l'ozone est
sur une tendance à la hausse l'an passé
11 épisodes de pollution ont été
constatées sur le territoire francilien
soit le nombre de journées de
dépassement le plus bas depuis 10 ans
airparif précise cependant que les
niveaux de pollution reste supérieur aux
recommandations de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé selon l'association
7900 décès prématurés liés à la
pollution pourrait être évités chaque
année
[Musique]
lena chic et créatrice de vêtements de
cycling elle récupère des vêtements
anciens taché ou inutilisable pour
confectionner des pièces de collection
elle a ainsi créé sa marque le porte
manteau j'ai fait ça parce que pour moi
ça me paraissait logique en fait quand
j'ai commencé à courir d'un coup je le
faisais quand j'étais petit je partais
pas de tissu je partais tour de
vêtements que j'avais déjà sur le
vêtement qui est déjà existants ben faut
s'adapter à ce qu'on a et j'aime bien ce
côté là j'adore les vêtements à motifs
et du coup c'est pour ça que c'est ce
que j'essaye de récré
quand je couds là ça va être des motifs
sur les manches
j'ai commencé avec les réseaux parce que
je n'avais pas de contacts donc que ça
fait que les réseaux ça permet vraiment
de se faire des contacts de voir aussi
si ça plaît parce qu'aussi au départ les
gens avant d'acheter ils vont suivre
parce qu' il aime ce que tu fais
au début les na devait travailler dans
une friperie parisienne en parallèle à
cette activité à leur secondaire quand
j'ai vu que ça commençait à prendre un
peu et qu'en fait le fait d'avoir de
travailler sur farhi rentrée de devoir
coudre le soir partir le matin et tout
ça prenait trop de temps bah j'ai arrêté
vu que je dois encore chez ma mère je
peux me permettre encore même si je
gagne pas mal il vraiment avec pour
l'instant avant j'avais le temps de
coudre mais c'est vrai que du coup je
n'avais pas le temps aussi de faire du
bon contenu pour les réseaux donner
envie aux gens d'acheter et entretenir
l'image de marque grâce au réseau
implique forcément quelques contraintes
une journée normale on va dire se finit
vers 18h 18h30 mais en fait c'est à
partir de ce moment là où les gens ils
sont sur leur téléphone sur les réseaux
et donc c'est à partir de ce moment là
qu'il faut poster nous pour que l'on
puisse être vu etc je prends la vidéo ce
qu'il faut c'est que j'ajoute une
musique il faut trouver la musique qui
va bien qu'il valait avec le style là
ok c'est pas mal on ajoute après faut
trouver la photo qui va être en
couverture
donc c'est la première photo que les
gens vont voir quand ils ont cliqué
dessus en fait on met la petite légende
et voilà et après on publie un essai
mais
j'adore le côté artistique on va dire de
quel genre de photo je pouvoir prendre
qu ils soient jolies quel genre de
vidéos qui peuvent être sympa etc mais
après par moments c'est quand même une
contrainte de se dire justement là il
est 18 heures il faut que je poste parce
que c'est là que les gens sont dispo à
20h la faudrait que je mette une story
parce que les gens ils sont sur leur
téléphone vers 21h un stade c'est génial
mais c'est horrible à la fois en fait
est que si on poste pas moi je vois la
différence entre quand je vais poster
super longtemps et je vais avoir je sais
pas 500 vues sur une story n'est qu'un
jour je pose pas le lendemain j'en ai 40
quoi aujourd'hui il enseigne le
portemanteau ne rapporte pas assez
d'argent à la créatrice pour en vivre ça
dépend des mois quand je fais les pop up
ça marche très bien parce qu'il ya des
gens
d'internet qui viennent plus les
passants parce qu'en fait aussi ce qu'il
faut ça c'est club cycling s'est pas non
plus donner des gens qui adorent qui me
met des commentaires qui trouvent que je
que je fais c'est trop beau mais causent
pas franchir le pas sur internet pour le
futur et une fois des revenus réguliers
assure elena aimerait bien franchir une
nouvelle étape embauché en salle a plus
qu'un atelier c'est vraiment ce qu'il
manque c'est plus être avec quelqu'un
réfléchir à deux pas forcément sur la
création mais tout ce qui est bas
justement
quelqu'un qui est qui et on va poster
quand qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour ça
et c'est à cela lui permettrait de
déléguer certaines tâches
administratives voire même sur les
réseaux et se consacrer pleinement à sa
véritable passion
loeb cycling j'espère que ça vous plaira
et on se retrouve bientôt pour la
première collection
on avait un tee shirt et le but c'est de
le transformer en débardeur avec une
manche avec une seule manche donc un
t-shirt comportait pas pour pouvoir le
réutiliser la tendance up cycling s'est
emparé de parly 2 le centre commercial
installé aux chaînés rocancourt organise
un atelier samedi 2 avril l'objectif du
jour repenser un t-shirt pièces
classiques que l'on trouve dans tous les
dressings en lui donnant une seconde vie
pour guider les participants
l'installera meuse ruby pigeon
spécialiste de la pratique c'est une
bonne manière d'apprendre assez
rapidement les déjà stress d'esprit des
transformations et en plus des bases de
couture pour qu'elle puisse le faire et
puis j'ai toujours attention à laquelle
vous êtes vraiment tout compris et
qu'elle puisse le faire à la maison
après sans moi quoique l'astuce et wat
d'avoir le temps à ne pas avoir peur de
se tromper et de prendre les tissus
clair parce que ça permet de voir où est
ce que le fils va quatre personnes ont
pu participer à cette animation
sélectionnés grâce à un concours sur
instagram lancée par le centre
commercial plus qu'une tendance loeb
cycling est pour elle une nouvelle
manière de consommer afin de lutter
contre le gaspillage
on souhaite réellement mettre en avant
la mode responsable qui est un
engagement qui nous tient vraiment à
coeur ça fait très longtemps que je fais
très attention à ma consommation que
j'achète des vêtements de seconde main
mais
je
ne sais pas encore
et reprendre
ce que j'apprenne donc là c'est une
première démarche à super intéressante
pour moi le seuil kling compte de plus
en plus d'adeptes en france où le
gaspillage est encore bien présent sur
600 mille tonnes de textiles vendus
moins d'un quart se retrouve aujourd'hui
dans les cycles de recyclage moi je
pense que tout est avec la web après
c'est vrai que ça n'a rien d'un obstacle
et à outrance si tu vas pas utiliser le
but quand même derrière c'est c'est que
ça soit utilisée à long terme et que et
que ce soit pas que ça finisse pas la
poubelle quand simplement
[Musique]
journée spéciale pour ces étudiants de
l'estaca aujourd'hui lucas etienne et
plusieurs membres de leur équipe col des
stickers sur leur première voiture de
rallye une grande étape dans leurs
projets automobiles ça fait plaisir
c'est un projet qui sa boutique mine de
rien on commence à voir
l'échéance arrivait donc donc c'est
sympa une nouvelle étape pour ce projet
imaginé pendant le premier confinement
mais 2020 par lucas et qui prend forme
depuis la rentrée 2021 aux côtés
d'étienne tous deux novices dans ce
secteur l'objectif de ces deux
passionnés de sport automobile être la
première équipe 100% étudiante à prendre
le départ d'un rallye et à le terminer
on avait vraiment envie de remettre en
avant le sport automobile mais pas sur
le domaine du circuit le circuit c'est
quelque chose que on a l'occasion
d'avoir un petit peu partout et on avait
envie de partir sur rallye puisque
malheureusement le rallye c'est une
discipline qui est peu mis en avant dans
aujourd'hui dans le sport automobile
bien qu' on est des grands champions
comme un sébastien loeb sébastien ogier
aujourd'hui le projet mobilise une
trentaine de personnes de l'école
d'ingénieur il prépare cette voiture
achetée 12000 euros pour la rendre
compétitive comme voiture de base c'est
une 106 s16 donc elle est préparée donc
n 2 même top n2 donc en n2 c'est une
catégorie de rallions on prépare les
voitures mais le but c'est de rester sur
vraiment un petit budget donc elle est
assez préparés andrieu basiquement c'est
à dire on l'intérêt évident et il ya un
arceau
voilà le moteur est juste
reprogrammer un peu mais après tout le
reste ça reste d'origine après plusieurs
mois de travaux et des dizaines d'heures
passées chaque semaine sur la mécanique
le bolide est presque terminée les
sportifs pourront enfin prendre la route
après des mois d'entraînement sur
simulateur la voiture devrait participer
à sa première course début mai au rallye
du coeur de lion dans l'eure donc on a
des sièges qui sont assez spécifique
qu'il faut homologué environ tous les
trois quatre ans donc cela sont encore
homologué ainsi que les harnais c'est
pareil à une homologation de 3 4 ans
ensuite on a ce qui nous permet de
survivre au cas où s'il ya un arbre qui
traversent la route donc les arceaux
c'est à dire que c'est une une cage en
métal en acier qui a s'est renforcé à
ses pairs au revoir on peut taper dedans
c'est cesser complètement plein au total
les deux étudiants devraient prendre le
volant sur quatre courses avant la fin
de l'été leur objectif terminer les
courses dans un premier temps et
pourquoi pas viser un top 10 en fin de
saison
[Musique]
et puis la ville de ben vient
d'inaugurer trois boîtes à lire à
proximité des trois groupes scolaires de
la commune elles ont été fabriquées par
christophe royan menuisiers des services
techniques de la ville et décoré par
trois artistes yvelinois claudia qu'en
post jean-françois ernotte et lucile
olivier le principe est simple vous
déposez un livre en bon état quand vous
voulez et où vous voulez pour que
quelqu'un d'autre puisse le découvrir
ces boîtes à lire sont accessibles 24
heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7 belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]